the first shells in this war first
landed on buckmut on the 17th of May
last year and that's almost a complete
year ago over a couple of days and in
that year bachmart has been reduced to a
ruin but this week it began to change a
little bit there have been some
counter-attacks by the ukrainians on
Tuesday the fifth assault Brigade
actually pushed to the South and around
the area of of ivanisk and that began to
outflank back much to the South and then
the 10th Mountain Brigade assault
Brigade assault Mountain Brigade began
to push to the north to uh towards
buddhistka and that created a second
locus of attack and what is happening in
Bachmann now may become irrelevant if
the ukrainians are able to complete the
circle if they're able to push both
north and south of bakmud and surround
the Russians who are bombarding the city
we'll see it might be a big ass but
undoubtedly that's what ukrainians are
trying to do and they're trying to worry
their Russians by launching these quite
strong counter-attacks north and south
of the city and Russians have clearly
withdrawn from those areas to three or
four kilometers away and they've left
the Wagner troops who are in the middle
of back much exposed both on North and
South both of those flanks so the
question is is this the beginning of the
big Ukrainian offensive well it's
certainly an offensive action and to
understand it we need to see it in
context with everything else that's
going on and so the ukrainians might
push in the next week or two at cremina
where they fought for very strongly
solidar which they're quite close to
already have difficult which they fought
very very hard over and vuladar where
they've withstood constant Russian
attacks but not actually given much
ground and so the ukrainians might well
try to as it would push the Russians
pressure them in any one of these places
to make the Russians commit their
reserves so they can see where the gaps
are going to open up but this is only
one front in a very big front if we look
at the whole front between Russia and
Ukraine the fighting front that's 960
kilometers long and anywhere along that
front the ukrainians might try to launch
their offensive maybe up in the uh the
the northern part the Northeast in khaki
Province maybe to push much more
strongly in the Dom that's to get back a
lot of the territories that they have
lost
quite likely somewhere in the South if
they can to cut the land bridge between
the donbass and Crimea which is just off
this map to the South or maybe in the
southwest uh in cursing where they
already did very well before Christmas
they might try to get across the Nipper
River when commanders are thinking about
this they have to think about how to
fool their opponent it's like a game of
chess between commanders how to uh how
to as it were a faint and decoy to make
the other side commit more troops
quickly in order to see where the gaps
are and that game of chess looks as if
it's beginning now in bakmut the
ukrainians have a good reason to try to
hold back mud for symbolic reasons but I
bet I bet this is not the locus of the
main attack it may be part of it but I
bet this is only part of a preliminary
process that the ukrainians are going
through
meanwhile at the other end of the world
uh the politics of this goes on in South
Africa this ship the lady R which is a
ship belonging to a Russian Transit
company called uh transmor form they're
trans more flot uh which is already
sanctioned by the United States it's an
illegal company in the US View and this
ship to Lady R came down the west coast
of Africa docked with its transponders
turned off in simonstown which is the
Naval Base next to Cape Town in South
Africa it unloaded and loaded during the
night only ever during nighttime hours
and then again with its transponders off
it left and is on its way back or has
been on its way back for some time now
to the Black Sea and so this is a ship
behaving very suspiciously on behalf of
Russia the Americans this week said that
this ship they think is carrying arms
from South Africa to Russia and that's a
big political issue for both South
Africa and the United States the South
African government have said well we'll
investigate it there's something wrong
here but we don't believe that that's
the case the Americans have gone public
on this which is actually quite a big
thing to do and South Africa is is going
to be embarrassed by this because
officially South Africa is neutral in
the war British neutrality has been
questioned by the visit of lavrov the
foreign minister of Russia not so long
ago joint exercises with uh with Russia
and with China a couple of months ago
and the general attitude which the South
African government takes towards the war
this is one big diplomatic spat at the
moment I think it'll run for a while yet
but it indicates a much bigger uh battle
which is taking place as the Ukrainian
defensive gets going and that is the
battle for World opinion the battle
between the Western view of this war
that it's a fundamentally important War
about Freedom democracy and the march of
the dictatorships in the world as
opposed to the global South and South
Africa is very important country in the
global South who just don't see it in
that way